OGE UDE: Music theater at
Princeton, and specifically
on this project, has
been a huge journey.
So much of my focus has been on
theater projects and the dance
projects that I'm
working on at the time.
It makes me make
sure that if I'm
going to go take a class,
if I'm going to do anything
academically, I need to
make sure I'm reflecting
on my artistic practice.
And if I'm going to be
taking so much time doing
my artistic practice,
I need to be sure
that my academic work
is coming into it.
The lesson to you
right now
is begin just recollecting
all that we did yesterday.
It's really helped me in terms
of just becoming a better
listener, becoming more
aware of what's around me,
and just trying to see and make
the connections in all that I
do.
I learn something in an English
class, and I'm just like,
this makes so much more sense
to how I see this scene.
And so it's just
been a great way
to channel in the entire
spectrum of my Princeton
education and then my
entire personal experience.